[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى هذه الصور ما زالترد من
غزه وتنقلوا مشهد ما بعد الفجر
عائله باكملها سنكون بعد قليل في متابعه
مع مراسلنا من غزه
وهذه الصور لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه تاتي
والعلم يترقبوا مقالات المهمه الاخيره
لوكاله ناسا التي هي اطلقتها الصاروخ
ارتمس تمهيدا لاول رحله ماهوله الى القمر
منذ 40 عاما
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
وفاه 21 شخصا من عائله واحده بحريق دلعها
في بنايه سكنيه بمخيم جباليا شمال القطاع
غزه القوى الفلسطينيه في القطاعات العام
والاضراب الشام الحداد على ارواح ضحايا
والسلطه الفلسطينيه تعلن الحداد وتامر
بتنكيس الاعلام وتطالب اسرائيل بفتح معبر
بيت حانون لنقل المصابين
بعد ضمانات الامميه بشان رفع القيود عن
صادراتها من الحبوب والاسمده روسيا توافق
على تمديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
ل 120 يوما اردوغان يؤكد ان الاتفاق اتاح
ايصال اكثر من 11 مليون طن من الاغذيه
للمحتاجين والامم المتحده تشدد على اهميته
لتجنيب العالم ازمه غذائيه
بالتزامن مع طلب اوكرانيا جديد بالحصول
على نظام باتريوس الامريكي للدفاع الجوي
موسكو تحذر من مغبه تسليم انواع محدده من
الاسلحه لكيف وتقول ان واشنطن تتورط بشكل
اعمق في النزاع وسلطات الاوكرانيه تتهم
القوات الروسيه باستهداف منشات للطاقه في
كيف اوديسا ودنيوجيا
الملف النووي الايراني نحو مزيدا من
التعقيد الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
تعتمد قرارا يامر طهران بالتعاون مع
تحقيقها بشان اثار يورانيوم في ثلاثه
مواقع ايرانيه بيان فرنسي بريطاني الماني
يصف الانشطه الايرانيه بالتصعيد النووي
غير المسبوق وظهران تهدد وتقول ان الوثائق
التي قدمت حقيقيه
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الاحتجاجات المطلوبيه التي
شهدتها مدينه صفاقس التونسيه ضد ما وصف
باهمال السلطات للوضع البيئي اسره تراكم
النفايات وحرقها في شوارع المدينه حيث طلب
المحتاجون باقاله المحافظ في ما رد الرئيس
البلديه بان الازمه مفتعله هذا المشهد
ياتي ضمن تراجع انك اقتصاديا صعب تعيش
البلاد كما قلنا وزاره الماليه تونسيه
اعلنت ان الدين العام بلغ نحو خمسه
وثلاثين مليار دولار والاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال الثالث كيف ستعامل السلطات
التونسيه مع ظرف الاقتصادي في ظل الازمه
السياسيه التي تعيشها البلاد ثلاثه
وثلاثون في المئه قالوا انها ستمضي قدما
في اجراءتها الحاليه
خيار البحث عن حل من بوابه الحوار السياسي
اما سبعه واربعون في المئه اعتبروا ان
السلطات ستراوح مكانها في مربع الازمه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وان نتطرقوا خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودونيا
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
وترودو سيجال تصطاده الكاميرات
[موسيقى]
نقله مراسل الجزيره في قطاع غزه عن مصر
طبيا قوله واحده
في بنايه سكنيه في منطقه تل الزعتر بمخيم
جباليا شماليه القطاع وقالت وزاره
الداخليه في غزه
انها دفعت بقوات كبيره من طواقم الدفاع
المدني والشرطه
للتعاملي مع الحادث
من مخيم جباليا شمال قطاع غزه مراسلنا
وائل الدحدوح وائل ما الذي جرى وكيف يبدو
المشهد الان
الذي جرى هو اندلاع حريق في الطابق الرابع
من احدى البنايات السكنيه وهو الطابق
الاخير في منطقه تل الزعتر بمخيم جباليا
شمال قطاع غزه هذا الحريق اندلع بشكل
مفاجئ بينما كان سكان هذا الطابق من
المنزل يقومون بعمليه ترحيب واحتفال باحد
ابنائهم الذين قدموا من السفر
للتوي بعد ان حصل على شهاده الدكتوراه
وكما يبدو حسب المصادر الطبيه
وزاره الداخليه هنا فان كميات من ماده
البنزين المشتعله كما يبدو كانت في مخزنه
في احد زوايا هذا المنزل تعلمون بان واقع
الحصار يفرض على كثير من الناس احتواء او
تخزين هذه المواد لاستخدامها في همم تشغيل
المولدات عندما تنقطع الكهرباء في قطاع
غزه وما اكثر انقطاع الكهرباء القطاع
وبالتالي
يبدو ان هذه المواد المشتعله ساهمت في
اشتعال النيران بشكل كبير جدا لدرجه منع
اي واحد من افراد المنزل الذين كانوا
بداخل هذه الشقه من الخروج والنجاه بنفسه
وبالتالي اصبح كل من كان بداخل هذا الطابق
همم يعني اصبح ضحيه وتوفي بالفعل وحسب
المصادر الطبيه والجهات الامنيه هنا في
قطاع غزه اعلنت الاحصائيه النهائيه قبل
قليل وقالت بان احد همم 21 من افراد هذا
المنزل بينهم الاب والام والابناء وكل من
كان برفقتهم في هذه في هذا الطابق همم
توفوا بالفعل بالفعل الحريق وكانت المشاهد
هي مشاهد مروعه وصادمه حقيقه الاعتبار ان
فاهمين كانت متفحمه نظرا لاشتعال النيران
طواقم الدفاع المدني الاسعاف هرعوا الى
المكان لكن الحريق كان هائلا وعلى طبقات
عاليه جدا بحيث ان همم تمكنوا من السيطره
على على النيران ولكن بالتاكيد بعد ان
التهمت كل محتويات ومقتنيات هذا المنزل
بشق الانفس وبعد جهد جهيد بالتاكيد تمكنا
من الدخول بشكل خاص الى هذه البنايه
وبالتحديد في الطابق الذي كانت النيران
فيه مشتعله
وتمكنا من تسجيل هذا التقرير على عجل
هذا ما تبقى من المنزل المحترف في منطقه
تل الزعتر بمخيم جباليا شمال قطاع غزه
اصبح اثرا بعد عين قطع متناثره متفحمه
الاسقف تشققت وتساقطت منها اجزاء كبيره
هذه واحده من الغرف بطبيعه الحال نحن بشق
الانفس استطعنا ان نصل الى هنا ويحاولون
ابعادنا من المكان لخطورته حقيقه الامر
ولكن حسب المعلومات التي تتردد حتى الان
اخر احصائيه تقول ان هناك همم 21 شخص هم
افراد وسكان هذا البيت في الطابق الرابع
من هذا المنزل اصبحوا ما بين قتيل وجريح
في المستشفى وما زالت فرق الدفاع المدني
والاجهزه الامنيه تقوم بعمليات التحقيقات
لحصر الاسباب والملابسات والتداعيات
لمعرفه السبب نسوان كان هناك احاديث تتحدث
عن وجود بعض همم
المقتنيات من البنزين والمواد المشتعله
خلال عمليه احتفال في هذا المنزل هو الذي
ساعد في عمليه الاحتراق لكن هناك اسباب
عديده حتى الان همم الاجهزه الامنيه هنا
تقول بانها ما تزال فتحت تحقيقا وسوف تكمل
هذا التحقيق تمهيدا للاعلان عن نتائجه همم
في الساعات القادمه وائل دحدوح الجزيره تل
الزعتر جباليا
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان تمديدات
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب ل 120 يوما اعتبارا من
التاسعه عشر من الشهر الجاري بدورها رحبه
الامم المتحده بتمديد الاتفاق الذي ساعد
على تفادي ازمه غذائيه عالميه وفي موسكو
لا حديث عن تمديد صفقه الحبوب لاجل غير
مسمى واضاف انا موسكو
رفع القيود عن الصادرات الروسيه من
الاسمده والسلع الغذائيه في اطار صفقه
الحبوب
120 يوما اخرى تضاف الى الاتفاقين
للموقعين في اسطنبول في يوليو الماضي
لتصدير الحبوب والذين يهد الثاني الى
تخفيف نقص الغذاء العالمي وسمح الاتفاق
حينها بانشاء ممرات بحريه تنطلق من ثلاثه
موانئ اوكرانيه لتصدير الحبوب هي اوديس
ويزني وتضمن الاتفاقه
عن التنسيق والرقابه وتفتيش السفن لاسيه
ما لدى عودتها للموانئ الاوكرانيه
قبل اربعه اشهر شحن اكثر من 11 مليون طن
من المنتجات الزراعيه وبلغت شحنه الحبوب
وحدها ثلاثه ملايين ومئتين الف طن وكانت
كيف تطمح ان يسمح الاتفاق باضافه الموانئ
الجنوبيه في منطقه ميكو لايف وهي ثاني
اكبر محطه للحبوب في اوكرانيا وفقا
لبيانات الشحن للعام الماضي كما شكت رو
مرارا من ان شحنتها من الحبوب والاسمده لا
تصل الى الاسواق العالميه بسبب العقوبات
التي تقييد حصول شركات الشحن على التمويل
والتامين ودخول المانع موسكو شددت على ان
اتفاقيه الحبوب تجدد تلقائيا اذا لم يكن
هناك اي اعتراضات وانه يجب حل جميع
القضايا المتعلقه برفع القيود على تصدير
المواد الغذائيه والاسمده الروسيه في غضون
120 يوما وهو مؤكده الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيرش بقوله ان المنظمه
الدوليه ملتزمه بازاله اي عقبات في طريق
تصدير الاغذيه والاسمده من روسيا
تويتر
المعهد معهد الدراسات الاستراتيجيه سيد
مركوب مرحبا بك معنا ما الذي مهد لتمديد
هذا الاتفاق ل120 يوما بالرغم من الشكاوى
الروسيه بان صادراتها لا تصل الى الاسواق
العالميه بسبب العقوبه
في كثير من الدول حيث
حيث ان اسعار المواد الزراعيه تزداد
ارتفاعا ونتائج ذلك فان مئات ملايين
بل حتى مليارات من البشر
يعيشون بصعوبه بسبب عدم حصولهم على ما
يكفي من وجبات غذائيه
والنعم بالتاكيد ان انت محققه تماما فان
الدول الغربيه لا لم توفي بالتزاماتها
ووعودها
بالسماح اللي همم
حبوب الروسيه لاسواق الدوليه وقومه تعلمون
ان اعداد وكميات القمح الروسيه ثلاث مرات
اكثر من ارقام حول الحبوب والاكرانيه
وبالتالي هي اكثر اهميه
للاسواقي والشعوب وان الامين العام الامم
المتحده قد قدم وعوده عده مرات في تحقيق
ذلك وان الرئيس الروسي وثق به وايضا وثق
بما قاله الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
الذي هو ايضا
سيضغط على الدول الغربيه
[موسيقى]
التي عليها ان ان تزيد كل العقبات امام
تصدير الحبوب الروسيه الاسواق الدوليه
لتحقيق هذه الوعود نتيجه الضمانات التي
منحت لموسكو يعني كي لا يجري ما جرى في
المره السابقه في الاتفاق السابق
ان حقيقه ان روسيا همم توقفت في مره واحده
عن او اوقف هذا هذا الاتفاق والنقل الحبوب
الاوكرانيه فهذا يثبت ويبين الدول الغربيه
بان همم ردود فعل روسيا قد تكون خطيره وان
روسيا قادره على ايقاف هذا تصديرها هذه
الحبوب
هو اعتقد ان هذا هو الدور الرئيسي ولكن من
جانب اخر طبعا
ليس مئه بالمئه
الدول الغربيه
او تحترم هذا الاتفاق نحن نعلم من هذه
الدول الغربيه لا تسير على على طرق
الدبلوماسيه ولا يحترم كل المعادات اذا
الدول الغربيه تتصرف
كانها
شعوبيه في الغابه
[موسيقى]
الاستراتيجيه شكرا لك
ونرحب بضيفنا ايضا في ميله مستشار الرئيس
الاوكرانيه سيدتنا في مرحبا بك معنا ما
نوع العقبات التي تم التجاوزها في اتفاق
الحبوب الحالي الذي جرى تمديده لمده 120
يوما
الوحيد
روسيا لاوكرانيا
الشعوب الشركات
من شحنه صفر خارج من اوكرانيا لانه روسيا
قد تهاجمها وبالتالي الاول ضمن بان عدم
حصوله ذلك ولكن في وقت ما قالت لان لا
تحترم الارتفاع
ولكن نحن قلنا سنواصل التركي
ارتفاع اذا الان روسيا قد عادت الى
الاتفاق لان الحقيقه
ولا يمكن ايقاف السفن تخرج من اوكرانيا
في الاتفاق الحالي عن ما جرى الاتفاق عليه
في المره الماضيه ويعني كانت هناك عقبات
خصوصا
هذا الاتفاق في الواقع
تحققت مع الحكومه هذا اتفاق بالضبط نفس
الاتفاق السابق
ولقد سالته بشكل واضح ان من كل المسؤولين
لماذا عادت روسيا الى هذا الاتفاق بل من
الذي اختلف فقالوا ان الشحنات استمرت
الجميع الاحوال وتركيا قالت بموضوع باناس
تواصل بالسماح لاوكرانيا بشحنه بحبوبها
حتى بدون موافقه روسيا وبالتالي يبقى اي
مجال امام روسيا هذا هو التفسير الرسمي
او العمل همم
هذه المره ما الذي سيمنع تكرار مثل هذا
الحادث في الاتفاق القادم
نتذكر ما حصل عندما علقوا التمثيل كان
هناك توقف في عمليات الشحن لمده ثلاث ايام
وبالتالي الموانع القران لم تشحن اي شيء
للثات ثم بعد ذلك بدات بالشحن مره اخرى
رغم ان روسيا سحبت من اتفاق اذا السفن
كانت تقاعد تغادر الموانع الاوكرانيه دون
وجوده روسي ولم يحصل اي شيء لهذه السفن
لهذا السبب فحاليا روسيا عادت الى مائده
فاذا ارادت انت تنسحب مره اخرى عليه الدفع
تستمر لتصدير ان الوضع عالي على ان روسيا
النهائي نفوذ او قطعه تاثير على الاتفاق
وبالتالي من الافضل لهما اللي ينظمه اليه
شكرا لك مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني من كيف
يتم
[موسيقى]
المشهد الميدانيه في الحرب الروسي على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت اوكرانيا ان روسيا شنت
هجمات
منشاه للطاقه ومصنع للصواريخ على مواقع
267 يوما ذكرت الاداره الاقليميه العسكريه
في كيف انها اسقط طائرتين انتحاريتين فوق
السد كيف لطاقه الكهربائيه وفي دنيترو
دوله انفجارات عده عقب غارات للطيران
الروسي ادت الى الانقطاع الكهرباء في
المدينه وقال رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ان
القصبه منشاته وبنا تحتيه ومصنعا للصواريخ
في المقاطعه اما في اوديسا فقالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه استهدف البنيه التحتيه في
المدينه واسفره عن جرحها كما قالتها اسقطت
صاروخ كروز وعدد من الطائرات المسير هاجمت
بها القوات الروسيه المدينه
في الجانب الذي تسيطر عليه روسيا على
نافاس السلطات المواليه لها اصابه مدنيين
وتدمير عدن من المنشات والمنازل في البنيه
التحتيه جراء القصف الاوكراني لعدد من
المناطق في اقليم دوم بس كل هذا القصف
ياتي في ظل الاستمرار المعارك لا سيما في
الجبهه الشرقيه حيث قالت مصادر عسكريه
لمراسل الجزيره ان اعنف الاشتباكات هناك
تجري على جبهتي بخموت وافديفكا
قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيين
تتفقان على ان روسيا تتحمل المسؤوليه
الكامله عن مواصفات الصاروخي وعواقبه في
اوكرانيا وبولندا ومالدوفا وكذا في اتصال
هاتفي مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه على
ضروره تسريع تسليم انظمه الدفاع الجوي الى
اوكرانيا
الروسيه ان الولايات المتحده تتورط بشكل
اعمق بالنزاعي في اوكرانيا
في صراع ساخن ومن توريد اسلحه من انواع
المحدده الى كيف
اعتمد مجلس محافظه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه قرارا يدعو ايران الى التعاون بشكل
عاجل مع تحقيق الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بشان اثار يورانيوم في ثلاثه مواقع
غير معلنه وعبره مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافاييل جروسي عن امله في
ان تتم زياره وفد الوكاله المقرره نهايه
هذا الشهر
بعدما ساد الاعتقاد ان مفاوضات فيينا على
وشك تحقيق هدف احياء الاتفاق النووي اعاده
اجواء التوتر والشك من جديد بين ايران
والاطراف الغربيه المشاركه في هذه
المفاوضات مجلس محافظ الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه صوت لصالح مشروع قرار قدمته
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا
والمانيا يدين عدم تعاون ايران مع الوكاله
لنصر القرار على انهم من المهم والعاجل ان
تتحرك ايران للوفاء بالتزاماتها القانونيه
يتعلق الامر هنا بما تقول الوكاله انها
اثار يونانيوم في ثلاثه مواقع غير معلنه
يعد هذا ثاني قرار من نوعه يصوت عليه
محافظ الوكاله هذا العام ما يشير الى ان
موضوع اثار اليورانيوم تحول الى اولويه
واصبح يغطي في الوقت الراهن على مواضيع
اكبر ايران اعلنت رفضها لمشروع القرار قبل
التصويت عليه قال محمد اسلامي مدير
الوكاله تاثير الطاقه الذريه انهم كتبوا
مشروع قرار وجاءوا بوفائك يعرفونهم انفسهم
انها ليست حقيقيه وان جمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه ترفضها بعد هذا التصويت زادت
الشكوك بشان زياره من المقرر ان يقوم بها
وفد من الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
نهايتها هذا الشهر الى ايران لبحث موضوع
اثار اليورانيوم مدير الوكاله رافاييل
روسي قال انه يتمنى ان تتم زياره المخطط
لها واضاف ان بعض الشقوق بدا التحوم
بشانها وتمنى ان توضح ايران موقفها يلمح
جروسي الى تصريح ادلى به مدير الوكاله
الايراني للطاقه الذريه محمد سلامه تسال
فيه عن ما اذا كانت هذه زيارته ستكون
مفيده في وقت يستعد فيه مجلس محافظ
الوكاله لتصويت لصالح قرار قدمته الدول
الغربيه الان وبعد تصويت محافظ الوكاله مع
ما يحمله من ادانه الايران يبدو ان ما
تقول الوكاله الدوليه للطا انها اثار
يونانيوم في ثلاثه مواقع غير معلنه قد
تحول الى نقطه خلاف اساسيه تهدد باعاده
مفاوضات احياء الاتفاق النووي الى المربع
الاول
مدير مشروع ايران في مجموعه الازمات
الدوليه سيد واعظ مرحبا بكم معنا ما الذي
سيترتب على قرار مجلس محافظي الوكاله
الصادر اليوم الذي يضاف الى اخر صدر
خلالها هذا هذه السنه بذات الخصوص
ا
فوريه من حيث
ايران ملف ايران الى
المجلس الامن الدولي هو خطه اخرى في ذلك
الطريق لكن دون مستوى الاحاله الرسميه
اللهجه القرار كان التقوى بكثير من القرار
الذي صدر في الصيف والذي سبق ذلك في العام
ايضا 2020 لكن يبدو ان الامور تتجه
تدريجيا باتجاه حاله الملف الى مجلس الامن
السؤال هو كيف ستردرام لانه في الصيف
ايران سرعت من الوتيره برنامجتها النوويه
وقللت من قدره الوكاله على الذهاب
والتحقق سنرى كيف سترد هذه المره ايضا
مثل هذا القرار وايضا ان نفي الايراني
والاصرار بان الطرف الغربي لا يقبل
بالوثائق المقدمه يوسع من ازمه الثقه
الاساء اساسا التي هي كبيره وموجوده بين
الجانبين
من خلال منظور اكبر وهو الحركه الاحتجاجات
المستمره في ايران والتي تزداد ايران عنفا
في قمعها مساله استخدام السيارات
الايرانيه ايضا امور اخرى كل هذه القضايا
العالقه ايضا مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه كلها تؤدي في النهايه الى خلق وضع
خطير في الحقيقه لاننا ان نمر بالدوره من
التصعيد ولا يبدو ان هناك احتمال تراجع
واذا ما استمرينا على هذا والله اذا ما
اخذنا بعين الاعتبار كم قريبه هي ايران
الى انتاج السلاح في الامر خطوره في
بدايتها العام المقبل
ايران في مجموعه
افاده بيان على موقع وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه بفرض عقوبات على شركات نفط وغاز
على صله بقطاع الطاقه الايراني وفقا
للبيان واضاف البيان وان العقوبات شملت 13
شركه في عده بلدان من بينها الصين ودوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده
قال قائد القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
الجنرال مايكل كوريلا تعليقا على زيارته
للسعوديه ان القياده الوسطى ملتزمه تجاه
شركاء الولايات المتحده العسكريين في
المنطقه وازااء العلاقات العسكريه
الامريكيه السعوديه واكد ان الالتزام
الامريكي بامن المنطقه ثابته ودائن وشارك
قائد القياده الوصفه الامريكيه في اجتماعي
لجنه التخطيط المشتركه العسكريه واناقش
المسؤولون العسكريون الامريكيون
والسعوديون فرصه عزيزه تعون العسكريه
الامريكيه السعوديه وتعزيز الامنيه
والاستقراري في الشرق الاوسط
تظاهرات ونقابات عماليه وعدد من اهالي
مدينه صفاقس التونسيه امام مقر المحافظه
للاحتجاج على تراكم النفايات وحرقها في
شوارع المدينه رفع المحتاجون فيها شعارات
تردد بما وصفوه باهمال السلطات تجاه تدهور
الوضع البيئي في المدينه كما طلبوا باقاله
المحافظ بسبب عدم معالجه تراكم النفايات
منذ اكثر من عام وقال رئيس بلديه صفاقس
منير اللومي انها حرائق النفايات مفعله
ويراد من خلالها تعطيل واعاقه الحمله
المكثفه لرفع اكوام النفايات المتراكمه
والتي شرعت فيها بلديه الولايه حسب قوله
وكان رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قد قال ان من
يتحدث عن امكانيات اسقاط الدوله سيكون
مكانه مزبله التاريخ على حد وصفه واشار
سعيد خلال لقائه بوزيره البيئه لبحثي
تراكم النفايات في مدينه الصفاقس لان
الحديث عن اسقاط الدوله ضرب من الوهم وفق
تعبيره
يتحدث عن امكانيه اسقاط الدوله فهو وهم
فهو مره اخرى في مزبله التاريخ وهو مكانه
في هذه القمامه التي تركها تتراكم على مر
الاشهر
من جانبيه قال علي الاعراض النائب رئيس
حركه النهضه انه لا تتوفر رؤيا للاصلاح في
تونس حاليا مضيفا ان الاوضاع عادت الى
وراء الوراء في ظل حكم سعيد وفق تعبيره
واوضح العريض ان تون استشهدوا موجه من
المحاكمات السياسيه شملت صحفيين ومحامينا
وسياسيين واشار الى ان الرئيس سعيد لا
يمتلكه الا الهوس بالسلطه وانا ما يفعله
لا علاقه له باراده الشعب التونسي على حد
تعبيره
مثل هالوقت هدايا 17 نوفمبر
في الديمقراطيه
مشروع الميزانيه بتاعت 23 يكون عنده شعر
ومهرين في البرلمان التونسي
هذا وقت اللي كان ثم برلمان وقلي كم تم
ديمقراطيه توا حتى حد ما يعرف
مشروع ميزانيه 2023
في الاشهر الاخيره
مع تراجع الكثير من المؤشرات الاقتصاديه
وتاخر الحكومه في تسليم رواتب الموظفين
لماذا يخرج التونسيون للاحتجاج في الشوارع
وامام المؤسسات الرسميه لا يتعلق التساؤل
هنا بالنخبي والاحزاب السياسيه المعارضه
للرئيس قيس سعيد التي اعتادت الاحتجاجات
والتمديد باجراءاته وقراراته منذ الخامسه
والعشرين من يوليو العام الماضي اذ ان
نسبه الاكبر من خريطه الاحتجاجات في تونس
في الاشهر الاخيره اصبحت تتركز على انتقاد
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه وعلى فشل
الدوله بتامين السلع الاساسيه وصولا الى
تعثرها المالي تجاهها موظفيها في المحتجون
في الشوارع ينتمون بمعظمهم الى فئات
الاجتماعيه وعماليه ومن ابناء القطاع
العام بل ان الحاله وصلت لاهالي صفاقس
شرقيه البلاد للاحتجاج على تراكم النفايات
وحرقها في شوارع المدينه ورفع المحتاجون
الذين انضمت اليهم نقابات عماليه شعارات
تمدد بما وصفوه باهمال تجاه تدهور الوضع
البيئي في المدينه كما طالبوا باقاله
المحافظ بسبب عدم معالجه تراكم النفايات
منذ اكثر من عام سبق ذلك في الرابع من
نوفمبر الجاري وقفات للعاملين في القطاع
الصحي في مختلف انحاء تونس احتجاج على
تاخر وعدم صرف الرواتب وللسبب ذاته كان
العاملون في قطاع النقل العمومي قد بداوا
الثاني من نوفمبر اضرابا مفتوحا عن العمل
في العاصمه تونس قبله بيوم تظاهر الاف
المعلمين العاملين بنظام الانتداب احتجاجا
على ما وصفوه بتنكر الحكومه لاتفاق سابقا
معهم كان يقضي بتسويه اوضاعهم المهنيه وقد
تسببت الاحتجاجات بتعثر الالتحاق مئات
الاله في من الطلاب بمدارسهم اما في
اكتوبر الماضي فقد شهدت مدينه جرجيس جنوب
الشرقيه البلاد موجه احتجاجات واضرابا
عاما تمديدا حامل السلطات مع كارثه غرق
قارب للهجره غير النظاميات قضى فيه عددا
من ابناء المدينه وغضبا من ترد الاوضاع
المعيشيه والاقتصاديه وفضلنا عن تعثر
الحكومات في تامين رواتب الموظفيها الذين
تزيد اعدادهم على 670,000 موظف فان القاسم
المشتركه لمئات الاحتجاجات التي شهدتها
مدن تونسيه منذ مطلع العام الحالي كان في
توالي موجات الغلاء في ظل رفع الدوله
الدعم عن المواد الاساسيه فضلا عن شرحها
واختفاء بعضها من الاسواق والترافق ذلك مع
تراجع قيمه الدينار التونسي امام الدولار
وارتفاع حاد في نسبه التضخم زاد على تسعه
في المئه وبلوغ الدين العام حاجز الخمسه
وثلاثين مليار دولار بنهايه اغسطس الماضي
حسب وزاره الماليه التونسيه
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث توصلت على اطراف الى
تفاهمات لانهاء الازمه السياسيه التي تمر
بها البلاد وقالت قوى الحريه والتغيير
جناح المجلس المركزي
مع الجيش
وافق على ابقاء مجلس الوزراء مدنيه
بالكامل بينما نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مصادر
عسكريه سودانيه قولها انها توصلت الى
تفاهمات مع قوى الحريه والتغيير ولكن لا
تزال هناك بنود عالقه
ضموا الينا من الخرطوم اللواء الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجدوب استاذ واداره الازمات
وفضل المنازعات كما نرحب ايضا بضيفنا من
الخرطوم عبد الخالق
بابكر قيادي في تحالفات تغيير الجذري
مرحبا بكما وابدا معك اللواء امين لماذا
الاعلان عن التوصل الى تفاهمات وامكانيات
توقيع اتفاقات لم تهدئ الشارع الغاضب
بدليل ما شاهده اليوم الشارع السوداني من
تظاهرات
جرى اغلاق الشوارع واستخدام القوه اا فيها
مساء الخير مرحب بيك ومرحبا السيد
المشاهدين وبضيفك الكريم حقيقه هذا
الاعلان من جانب هو الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي ياتي في اطار الحراك الذين
انتظام الساحه السياسيه بدءا من خطابات
السيد القائد العام
بتحزير رؤيا سياسيه معينه بالابتعاد عن
الجيش ثم اعاقب هذه الخطابات تكوين ما
يسمى بالجيش كيان الوطن
ثم الحركات
والتسويه ولذلك عمد ظهور الحريه والتغيير
على الاعلان وعقد مؤتمر صحفي لاستباق كل
هذه الحركات وتاكيد التسويه التي تتم
بينها وبين المكون العسكري اه ايضا المكون
العسكري
تحدث عن وجود تفاهمات ولم يتم التوصل الى
الاتفاق حتى الان ولكن في تقديري هذا
الاتفاق الايطالي ممتا يمكن البناء عليه
للوصول الى تسويه
تمهيد لانهاء الازمه السياسيه في السودان
وبالتالي يمكن لبغيه القوه والتحالفات
الموجوده في الساحه اللحاق بهذا الاتفاق
هذه الازمه والوصول الى الانتخابات طيب
سيد عبد الخالق بابكر انتم ترفضون في
تغيير الجذري اي نوع من التفاهمات ما بين
مكونات المدنيه وما بين المجلس العسكري
ولكن الحراك في الشارع في السودان مستمر
منذ عام وبزخم متفاوت وحتى الان لم يستطع
الشارع ان يفرض التغيير الجذري الذي ينادي
به هل هذا الحراك الثوري كافر برايك
طيب في البدايه اليوم 17 نوفمبر هي الذكرى
الاولى لمجزره 17 نوفمبر 20 21 بمدينه
البحرين التي استشهد فيها 15 شهيد من صور
مدينه بحرين
اليوم يصادف 17 الذكرى الاولى في سته
حالات بتعض اصابات بالراس موجود الان في
المستشفيات الخرطوم نتيجه القرعه المفرد
للسلطه للقوات العسكريه في شارع المعونه
في البهبهاني طيب في البدايه
العمليه العمليه السوريه في شارع مطور
ومتقدمه ومشهد خطوات كبيره جدا جدا
واحده من مظاهر التطور بتاع الحركه
السوريه هو رضوخ اللجنه الامنيه النظام
بتاع البشير في السلطه الانقلابيه
السياسيه لو جرينا
او تبعنا مسار الصناعه السياسيه
25 اكتوبر بانه البرهان اللي هو موجود في
راس السلطه كان بيتكلم حول انه هو ماشي في
اتجاه الت حكومه في 25 اكتوبر وبعداك ماشي
في انه يكون حكومه وما نجح في تكوين اي
حكومه وطيله السنه اللي فاتت ديه قال لنا
البرهان متكلم ان هو عمل تفهم وقعد مع
مجموعه بتاعه قوه مدنيه ده ده نتيجه حصار
الشارع
للسلطه السياسيه عشان كده اكبر ظلمان لانه
جدي متنازه ويقعد يتفرجوا
والتغيير بالنسبه
دوليه في على السودان الدوليه عملت ازمه
اقتصاديه بالمزيد من تبديد وتهريب موارد
السودان عملت ازمه باستعابه المشوه العمل
ازمه في ال- في العمل
قعد طرفيه كثيره جدا جدا في السودان طيب
عملت ازمه على مستوى خطير جدا جدا
اذهب للسيد اللواء امين همم يعني ما الذي
سيتغير الان لواء امين في همم المشهد حتى
يوافق المجلس العسكري على تقديم تنازلات
في نقاط يعني همم بنى عليها البرهان في
السنه الفائته قراراته همم تلك
ما حدث في 25 اكتوبر
والنيتاج لتنازعات في السلطه بين طرفي
الازمه مكونه العسكري والمكون المدني
فعلته ذلك خطابات متبادله خطابات كراهيه
وخطابات عدائيه ادت الى ما حدث في 25
اكتوبر الجميع ادلك الخطا
المكون المدني والمكون العسكري ويبدو ان
المجلس المركزي خطا خطوات صبغ بها الجميع
في همم الجلوس والتفاهم ووضع الاعلان
الدستوري المخترع همم بقيه التحالفات
الموجوده الان هذا التي تتمسك بماضي انتهى
همم الان الجميع يحس بان السودان في مازق
همم هنالك همم تسيب امني وذلك الضغط
اقتصادي لابد من وضع مصلحه السوداني همم
قبل المصالح الذاتيه للاحزاب والكيارات
والمجموعات لذلك ما دام الجميع اعترف
بالخطا ما دام الجميع يعمل على همم الوصول
الى تسويه همم تنقل السودان الى مرحله
الانتخابات والخروج من النفق يجب على
الجميع الان التوافقوا على الحد الادنى
والتنازل التوافق على الحد الادنى
والتنازل سيد عبد الخالق يعني في مفهوم
السياسه هناك خذ واعطي المعادلات الصفريه
يعني لا تنتج شيئا بالنهايه اللي الجميع
ما هي رهاناتكم في المرحله
المقبله عندما تنادون بالتغيير الجذري ولا
طالما اذا موضوعنا في الاذان انا طالما
كانت المؤسسه العسكريه منذ عقود حاضره
وبشكله متفاوت في عمليه حكم السودان
انا الاول انا الاوان لتغيير مسار الصراع
السياسي والاجتماعي في السودان انا الاوان
لايقاف نزيف موارد السودان انا الاوان
لتقدم قوه اجتماعيه ذات مصلحه في حكم
السودان المساله دي التاسيس بتاعه قاعد
يتم من خلال العمليه السوريه الموجود
الليله على المستوى شارع السودان
الجديد
القوه السوريه
اتكلم عن اضراب سياسي يتكلم عن عصيان مدني
للوصول لاسقاط الانجلاب الوصول لاسقاط
الانجاب وازاله شروط
شركات القوات الجيش لوزاره الماليه بوضع
الجهاز بتاع القوات القوه العسكريه داخل
ولايه وزاره الماليه المساله دي الاساليب
بتاع الانهار الانقلاب غير كده انقلاب
وغير كده الدائره الشريره في التاريخ لكم
اعلنت الحكومه البريطانيه حزمه اجراءات
اقتصاديه وماليه بهدف تحسين اداء اقتصاد
البلاد وتخفيف العبء المتزايده على كاهل
المواطنين واشارت احدث الاحصاءات الرسميه
في بريطانيا الى ارتفاع نسبه تضخم الى
اعلى مستوياتها منذ اكثر من 40 عاما
واضح اثر تراجع الاقتصادي على المواطن
البريطاني مواطن ارهقه ارتفاعه معدلات
التضخم في البلاد بشكل لم يتكرر خلال
الاعوام الاربعين الماضيه
عندما تذهب الى الاسواق تجد اسعار كل
الخضروات والفواكه
اكتوبر العام الماضي
في بريطانيا فقاء احد عشر في المئه
ارتفاعا انعكس بتفاوت في قطاعات عده تمسح
حياه المواطنين في طعامي اكثر من 16% في
السكن والمرافق اكثر من
26% وفي اسعار المواصلات نحو تسعه في
المئه
العام بنحو 30 مليار جنيه استرليني وزياده
الضرائب بنحو 25 مليار جنيه استرلينيه
[موسيقى]
نقدم اليوم خطه للتعامل مع ازمه نفقات
المعيشه اولويه نهى الاستقرار والنمو
والخدمه العامه
وتهدف الحكومه من خلال اجراءاتها الى سد
فجوه في الميزانيه العامه تقدر بعشرات
المليارات من الجنيهات الاسترلينيه فهل
تفلحسين
بهدف اعاده الاستقرار للميزانيه العامه في
المملكه المتحده وارسال اشاره بان فوضى
الاسابيع الاخيره انتهت وان الحكومه تخطط
لخبط عجز الميزانيه
حزب المحافظين الحاكم منذ اثني عشر عاما
يقولون التراجع الاقتصادي الحالي يعود
اساسا الى تداعيات حرب اوكرانيا وجائحه
كورونا على الاقتصاد العالمي ويقول
المنتقدون انه يعود كذلك الى اسباب اخرى
من اهمها سياسات اقتصاديه فاشله سينما في
عهد حكومه ليستراس السابقه
ان امامهم فترات عجافها يقدرها المتفائلون
باشهر ويقدرها المتشائمون بسنوات ويامل
الفريقان ان تصل اجراءاته الحكومه الولاده
الى بر الامان ولسان حال الجميع يقول عسى
ان يكون قريبا اسد الله الصاوي الجزيره
لندن
تعرض رئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن ترودو
لموقف محرجه على هامشي قمه العشرين في
اندونيسيا امس الاربعاء حيث رصدت
الكاميرات ما يبدو توبيخا له من الرئيس
الصيني في جنبين بشان تسريب ترودو للصحافه
محاور محادثات جرت بينهما مؤخرا وذلك قبل
ان ينسحب ترودو من القاعه لنتابع مصادته
الكاميرا
[موسيقى]
وزاره
رئيس سجن بيج مع رئيس الحكومه الكنديه
رودو هو وانعكاسهم لعلاقات متوتره بين
البلدين حتى عام 2017 كانت الصين اكبر
شريكا تجاريا لكندا في اسيا استيرادا
وتصديرا وفقا للاحصاءات صينيه فقط قفز حجب
تبادل التجاري بينهما من سبعه مليارات
دولار الى اكثر من 45
مليار دولار بين عامين 2001
و2016 كما تعتبر الصين اكبر مصدر للهجره
الى كندا في العقود الاخيره حيث اصبحت
مجموعه الكنديين الصينيين الان واحده من
اكبر المجموعات العراقيه في كندا لكن مع
اوائل عام 2018
اخذت العلاقات منحا مغير اثرا اعتقال كندا
لمين جوا المدير الماليه وابنه مؤسس شركه
هواوي الصينيه التكنولوجيا والاتصالات
بناء على طلب امريكي لاحقا اعتقلت اصلطات
الصينيه مواطنين كنديين وحكمتهما بتهمه
التجسس في خطوه اعتبرت انتقاميه وزاد
التوتر بين البلدين عندما اتهمت كندا
الصين قبل اسبوع بالتدخلي في انتخابات عبر
تمويل شبكه مرشحين يعملون لصالح بيجين
فضلا عن محاوله اقامته مراكز شرطه بشكل
غير قانوني في كندا للسيطره على الصينيين
المنفيين
كندا وصين تربطهما علاقاتهم منذ 80 عاما
وقد مرت بمراحل من المادي والجزر في عام
1942 ارسلت كندا رسميا سفيرا لها الى
الصين لاول مره لكن سرعانا ما كانت
القطيعه الدبلوماسيه بينهما عام
1949 اثرا انتصار الشيوعيين في الحرب
الاهليه الصينيه واحتاجه الامر الى نحو
عقدين من الزمن حتى تستانف العلاقه عام
1970 بعد 30 سنوات من ذلك زار رئيس
الوزراء الكنديه بيرث رودو جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه وذلك في تونس الحرب البارده ثم
ادى الزعيم الصيني زوجيه زياره الرسميه
الى كندا وكان اول قائد شيوعي يتحدث في
البرلمان الكناديل كلنا نذهب الى اوكس
ينضم الينا من هناك جوليو بوليسي وهو
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
المختص بشان الصيني بجامعه اوكسفورد سيد
بوليسي مرحبا بك معنا كيف تقيم العلاقه
الصينيه
الكنديه اليوم على ضوء هذه التوترات وصولا
الى متى بعناه امام الكاميرات لهذا السجال
الصيني والكندي
القضيه معقده جدا
من الممارسات الدبلوماسيه المحترمه ان لا
يتم تسريب
المناقشات انا اعتقد هذه هي المره الاولى
التي يقوم بها الزعيم الصيني بعد تاكيده
زعيما للمره الاخرى وبعدها اغلاقها الصين
بسبب
الجائحه وما الى ذلك علينا ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار
معطيات السياسه الداخليه
بسببي مزاعم تدخل الصين في الانتخابات
الكنديه وعدم اتخاذه موقفا قويا ازاءها هو
حاول ان يظهر انه يفعل شيء وخاطر جمهوره
الداخلي بهذه الطريقه
رياضيه ستكون عاملا دافعا لتحسين العلاقات
بعد ما شهدته اثرا اعتقال ابنه رئيس شركه
هواوي
نعم
هذه حقيقه
من المشكلات التي
تواجهها الاقتصادات في العالم طبعا
الصغيره ربما وليس المتحده الاقتصادات
الاصغر عندما تتعامل مع اقتصاد كبير مثل
الصين في الدرجه الرابعه في العالم
يحاولون احيانا فرض عقوبات او ما الى ذلك
لكن لا اعتقد اننا سنصل الى تلك المرحله
فرض عقوبات على الصين او مشاكل
ما اثر
ما وصف بانه يعني عباره عن حديث اقرب الى
التوبيخ من قبل الرئيس الصيني اللي رئيس
الوزراء الكندي على العلاقات وعلى مشهد
يعني السياسي داخل كندا وترودا وجهت له
انتقادات
كنت تتحدث عنها قبل قليل في خضم هذه
الانتخابات والتدخلات الصينيه
لانه على الرغم من انه او وقف ثابتا في
موقفه وهو يتعرض لما هذا التوبيخ ثمنه
كذلك
وتحدث
بروح النقاش الحر وان ينتقد المواقف
الصينيه لكن ايضا هو عطره في نفس الوقت
امام المعارضه في بلاده انه اتخذ موقفا
اذا اعتقد ان القضيه ستموت على على ان هذا
الحظ رغم انني لسته قادرا على تنقل
المستقبل
وكيف تنظر الى
النمو التاثير الصيني من خلال الزياده
الهجره الصينيه وهي الاكبر
قياسا بالنسبه المهاجرين الى كندا نموها
داخل همم كندا عوامل تاثيرها ان كان داخل
كندا وعلى العلاقات بين البلدين
هذه قضيه معقده والسؤال معقد للغايه لان
الكثير من تاثير الصين له علاقه
بالتاثير في شؤون الصينيين الذين يعيشون
خارج
البلاد والجاليات الصينيه التي تعيش خارج
الصين طبعا هذا هم يرتبطونه بامن النظام
وايضا مساله التجسس وانتهاك حقوق الملكيه
الفكريه رغم اننا لا نمتلك التفاصيل يقينا
لكن نسمع ان الصين حاولوا التدخل لدى
العاملين في الكونجرس على سبيل المثال من
خلال عرض رشا ماليه عليهم للاستفاده من
جهود الجاليه الصينيه او الكنديين من اصل
صيني في هذه الجوانب وهي مشكله مع ال مع
البلدان التي فيها جاليات صينيه كبيره
شكرا لك استاذ العلاقات همم الدوليه
المختص بشان الصيني بجامعه اكسفورد سيد
جوليو بوليزي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اياهم قليله ويبدا الحدث المرتقب كاس
العالم فرحه الشعوب واحلام طامحين في عالم
الرياضه طبعا لكن يحزن الكثيرين ان هذه
الفرحه سيغيب عنها البعض بكرا لاعبون
يجتهدون اعواما ليحققوا شيئا لبلدانهم ثم
يخطف كل شيء في لحظه وهذا ما وجهه نجم
منتخب السنغال ساديو الذي سيغيب عن
مونديال قطر 2022 لاصابه نالت من ساقيه
اليمنى اتمنى له الشفاء العاجل ونتمنى ان
يكون الحدث مساء حتى فرحين للجميع نهايه
الحصاد لهذه الليله تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]